bethenny is in south dakota hi Bethany
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you so much for taking my call sure okay
first you know Hill yeah well I own my
own direct sales business and I was just
I had the opportunity to take the master
financial training back in April and so
now I'm launching my coaching practice
so my question kinda has to do with
regarding balancing working from home by
you know running my business out of my
home and still taking on the duties of
taking care of a household and husband
and all of that and so I'm just curious
Christy does your husband work as well
and I guess how do you kind of tread
upstream of I just for me being a
stay-at-home mom but also owning my own
business and being the breadwinner I'm
finding that it's not not a common you
know scenario and in normal household
across America so I'm having a hard time
relating to other women when most of my
friends are now stay-at-home moms and
don't have a job outside at the home so
I guess how do you just balance all of
that and still being able to provide
time for your family and your business
and all of that
sure well this is a common question we
get probably more than anything else
because it is a challenge and I'll tell
you there's no perfect answer there's
not a perfect formula most of us are
just making it up as we go and it's
messy and that's okay but two things you
hit on that I want to touch on one is
does my spouse work and what does that
look like for us and he does and he also
travels he's actually out of town right
now and I travel as well and so there's
a real key factor that attributes to our
success which is being on the same team
and the way that you do that is you have
a conversation now if you're familiar
with Dave's teaching we teach you to get
on the same page with your family like
when you're making a budget and you want
to do that with your time as well so you
want to have a conversation with your
spouse about what are the expectations
for time for schedule for work for
commitments and priorities with your
time just like with your budget and then
it cuts out a lot of the resentment and
unmet expectations no we do a budget
with our calendar it's the same thing we
share says let's do calendars and she's
got one of those old-fashioned two-page
day at a glance things handwritten that
she gets out and
all right let's see where we're gonna be
this week in next week and I laid my
whole tour schedule out for the spring
right and it's all on there and then we
review it every so often but every so
often should get your computer window
calendar
there's mines on the computer ours is on
that stupid date timer thing but but I
mean you have you have to budget your
time like you do your money you do and
the thing is you can make more money but
you can't get more time your time is
finite you know my husband right now is
in Texas he comes home today and I leave
one Friday and I'm gone to LA and so you
have to be very intentional or it'll get
away from you the other thing that you
asked that Bethenny is you're talking
about how you really manage this when
working from home and it's very very
tempting when you work from home to not
treat it like a real job you stay in
your pajamas till 2:00 p.m. the day gets
away from you you get distracted with
chores you have got to treat your
business like a real job and you set a
schedule you have a space that you honor
and you protect you wake up you have a
time that you go to it and you treat it
like you have a real job because
otherwise it won't happen and so having
that that those kind of boundaries will
help you be successful we always joke
about this started on a card table in my
living room and it did and our kids were
little and you're right I had to learn
to get up like I've always gotten up
right five or six o'clock in the morning
and you know take my shower get dressed
go to work and I'm walking down to the
living room I didn't walk in there in my
house shoes right and I didn't walk in
there you know wearing my gym shorts
right every when there's sat down went
to work right and there's something
about that even with little kids it's
signaled them that that they had changed
yes and that that that's off-limits and
that they're not allowed to be standing
just outside that door screeching well
I'm on the phone with some guy trying to
do a deal on New York you know when I
get you the right mindset when you take
a shower and put on clothes and get
ready for the day you sit down to your
computer or your workspace more
energized and focus and ready and
committed to do the work versus just
kind of wandering in and out in your
pajamas I know it sounds fun and once in
a while that's fine but if you don't
take it seriously your work is not going
to be serious and the other thing that
you always say when you're teaching on
this subject is wherever you are
be present yes yes just having focus on
you know if you're working from home
it's very easy for your business to take
over your life or feel like your life
creeps in and distracts you from your
business but if whatever you're working
on having
we focus there and trying to tune out
some of those other things with those
boundaries of space or schedule or if
you need to get childcare and help that
will really help you be present in those
moments and then when you're off work
and you're out of that space and you're
in your pajamas and you're hanging out
with your kids you can be present there
as well yeah you don't pick up a cell
phone right yeah you don't check your
email while you're playing with your
child right you know you set it aside
it's do the thing you're there to do yes
the problem is is when we're sort of
working but we're playing with the kids
or sort of play the kids but we're
working that nobody's winning right
nobody's getting to all of you at that
point and that's where we mess up right
and women are really you know we pride
ourself on being great multitaskers but
there's a right and a wrong way to
multitask the right way to multitask is
when you give your attention in one area
and you maybe have other things going
like food in the crock-pot laundry going
that doesn't require your attention but
when you try to give your attention in
multiple spaces like to your children
and their homework and also doing orders
or on the you know something else
you're going to it's going to suffer
it's like talking to someone when
they're texting they're not paying
attention to you you can't give your
attention in multiple areas at one time
yep very cool hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you